oh my god [ __ ] amazing
so cool
we're set now dustin we're set now
[Music]
with the puff and productive puffin like
the whole concept of v-friends
was for me to build a universe of
characters
that
spoke to the things that i've been
speaking to as garyvee knowing that i'm
limited as one human being to get out
the message that i really want i wanted
to create my pokemon my disney there was
a these books when i first came to
america and learning how to speak
english called uh sweet pickles and they
were like these alliteration characters
and so that was like a big inspiration
in my whole life and then when i was
going to this i'm like oh that'd be cool
and so i wanted to do the alliteration
thing and so
productive
you know i you know i was just looking
up all sorts of animals like
the puffin just looked i mean like the
beak it just looked cool and just looks
[ __ ] focused and so
um
it's kind of an esoteric random
character like i don't think like people
love elephants and lions and giraffes
like nobody's rolling around and like
you know the puffin is my [ __ ] guy
so i kind of felt like
there's something about that underdog
mentality that allows the character to
be productive which is why i wanted to
do the puffin
yeah the whole thing's like [ __ ] it's
really well done
someone behind the camera asked what
excited you about collaborating with
paul
i mean you know not to embarrass him in
front of him but like you know there's
it's we like
the answer is like what what doesn't you
know as we started getting to know each
other virtually digitally
through social through the years
i mean he's a truly an actual icon in
his craft and i think the way he was
just referring to i needed to look
outside my own craft to be like wait
lebron does this like kobe did this
i've always kind of done that you know
because i i didn't have the luxury of
being an athlete even though i loved it
so much so for business i would always
look to
sports and other places and i've just
always really
you know appreciate a very specific
thing which is
someone that's great at something and is
nice
and i just loved through the years
nike executives
ran you know just you know i read so
much of people talking like even when we
first got connected i remember vividly
early early twitter
when twitter was super small
somebody tweeting like i mean super
small less than 100 000 people 500 000
people so you saw like everything
somebody
in san francisco tweeting that they ran
into him and how nice he was and it just
took note
that's fine i believe in that [ __ ] so
i think what made it interesting was i
knew that collaborations were going to
be a big part of be friends and i wanted
to do it with people i admired
brands that i thought were interesting
obviously ben is so close we try to be
very thoughtful of like
what are the right brands what
represents what we're trying to do
obviously his interest in the subject
matter and like when he brought paul was
that's exactly right like and so just
became very it became very easy mentally
to be like that's exactly what i want to
do
oh a long time
a long time
finally get to meet the guy in person
really it's super nice i mean like you
know people love to [ __ ] on technology
oh social's bad for this internet's bad
for this [ __ ] up everything
like this is the first time we're
meeting yeah i feel like i've known him
for 15 [ __ ] years like like people
love to look at the negative i tend to
look at the positive about things like
it's crazy the emotion and the energy i
feel
and that would not be possible without
social
and the internet and so i just wish
people
chose to look for the good i think we're
on a there's a lot of momentum right now
to choose to look at the bad and i think
we got to get out of that and so this is
a perfect real-life example of how much
good digital infrastructure can do
because relationships
are the most important thing in the
world
acquaintances friendships family love
so it's nice nice quick question
yeah were you always
prior to social media were you always
like a social person yes always around
yeah yeah i was
and i was and the way i show up in
social is very much how i showed up in
life i
am addicted to human interaction
and
all of it i really liked 80 year olds
when i was a kid i would sit with my
grandparents at the park and talk to
them i
had a very unique kind of like
you know i grew up in the 80s and 90s
where like high school and junior high
like like it was very like you couldn't
be popular unless you were willing to
compromise and pick on people and like
do that thing and i
really kind of like skated my way
through
meaning
i just never compromised on being kind
and was able to hang out with the cool
kids as much as like
the nerd kids and you see that in social
media now like the extremes people are
willing to go just for attention just
for views just for whatever like
well people people need outside people
people need outside validation
which is the framework that i'm trying
to talk to more people about which is
like why
why thank god like you know if you can
understand why you're looking for it and
what it you're trying to scratch and
what hole you're trying to fill you can
start reverse engineering it and doing
it in a healthier way than looking for
it out of flexing or
having stuff or compromising who you are
to get the laugh
or the or the
head nod yeah i think about that a lot
yeah man that's cool yeah well you were
lucky to be born with that disposition i
was born i was introverted shy kid super
shot didn't and that's why i think i
gravitated towards skateboarding right
it was it's it's it's
little league everything but like when i
found skateboard i can just go when i
want do what i want i didn't have to
like interact too hard with anybody i
was just
so introvert so when social media first
came around i didn't really get it i
didn't grasp it makes sense who's going
to care about what my food i had today
like like i don't why do i want to post
a picture of the food i had or whatever
i was just so like i don't get it and
then slowly but surely surely my partner
heath put me on to it and made me get
instagram and do all that i get it yeah
i get it it's funny um
i'm the reverse the reason i think i'm
an entrepreneur is i like to make things
for the world i want everybody to
interact with my stuff
um
but it's cool it's also cool to evolve
right like
you know for a lot for my all my
extroverted dna i love a good flight
where nobody can bother me i love the
shower shower is my favorite damn place
on earth but nobody's gonna bother me i
can't even be my my phone will get
[ __ ] up in here this is a good place
so like you know it's about
understanding what makes you tick and
one thing i've been really thinking a
lot about lately is letting people feel
comfortable to reframe their identity so
i've noticed some people
kind of always be known by being snarky
and cynical and introverted and they've
changed their mind in their late 20s
their 30s their 40s but they're almost
scared to go there because they're known
as this
and so i'm trying to think about how to
talk about that more which is like [ __ ]
changes yeah because if social media
wasn't around
naturally you're going to be a different
person from 20 to 30 from 30 to 40. look
at snoop dogg yeah that in 1992 the
snoop dogg that i discovered is very
different like [ __ ] changes yeah 100
and i think you know certain people do
it gracefully snoop dogg's a really good
example and they just do it because i
think they own who they are hundred
percent and they just move they just let
the evidence 100 and people kind of it
almost happens like unnoticed but but
you know it's it's hard because in snoop
scenario and for some of us in here a
little bit older majority aren't
in the 90s if you were going to be in
hip-hop you had to make pretend you were
hard even if you weren't
there was only one thing that worked in
hip-hop
you know timbo's starter jackets and
like killing people like it was just
super like that and so
for a lot of people if they love skate
or bmx or food or wine or business
there's this the culture of the moment
has a certain thing
and it's hard to be an individual within
it when you love a genre it's a really
interesting challenge for a lot of
people but the more we pound it the more
we can have creative things happen
absolutely like in skating it was kind
of like um
the taboo to work out and train like a
real athlete there's like man just
[ __ ] skate bro that's right that's
your workout you skated today like and
then you know that's why you're 25 years
old and you feel like you get back yeah
and you're like yes because you don't
know what a foam roller is guys like you
don't know soft tissue work
yeah like like fascia next thing you
know
oh great i'm 37 i still feel great like
cool cool all right who's upset now his
bum now you just have to i guess that
long-term vision will carry you past all
that
uh you know makes a lot of sense it
makes a lot of sense
someone behind the camera asks to paul
what does it finally mean to meet gary
in person
after observing him on social media for
so long oh i'm i'm tripping out right
now it's scary
i'm tripping out we're here in the skate
park and he's here standing in the skate
park and we're talking about a collab
we're doing together it's crazy because
there's so many i mean as with so many
people in the world like you just go on
gary's page
in any one of his socials and you just
catch a snip and you're like holy [ __ ]
that's what i'm going through right now
like and you're talking to some kid or
somebody who just came up and you just
it's impressive to me like how like no
matter what the subject or what the
question is you just have a straight
stream of consciousness for whatever it
is boom here's what he learned like how
is he so
clear-minded on that answer right there
instantly and i'm it's so impressive to
me you know back to the correlations
it's why i get other people that are
great at certain things
like for the last like four years i'm
like man
if i had a sense
even an ounce
of rhythm
soul or any music capability i could be
a crazy rapper
but i have zero
it comes to me but there's like a like
all the words like it's how i talk it
all works and then the pipe of any
musical capability at all doesn't exist
in my
body and thus it breaks
and then i watch people do it
and i'm just so impressed
like lil wayne going into the booth and
just spitting from the top of head and
leaving is how i do that
there is literally nothing that anybody
here can come up to me and talk about
that doesn't come super simple to me
because it's complete clarity for me on
life that's crazy but i can't do that of
the things i want to say under the genre
of the context of music and i want to
and so like when people want to do like
the way i speak or this i'm like i get
it i'm like i'm not sure but like for
you like the the symmetry or like seeing
it or innovating
like innovating i think comes from that
as well like when you can see something
that nobody else can see and then you do
it
everyone's like completely taken aback
but for the person that's doing it
you're like you're like what do you mean
yeah like it's like waking up yeah like
and so
i'm very flattered by that and i think
the thing that i'm most passionate about
is getting everybody understand
that they should fight to figure out
what that thing is for themselves and
even if it's something small
to the world it's big to you for example
my thing
and your thing actually
and let's talk video game skateboarding
and entrepreneurship 1987. i was 12.
you're looking at the world of what do
you want to be what do you want to do
there's not one person you can look at
that
is
an entrepreneur the word didn't even
[ __ ] exist
there was like business people but they
were like oh they're like 80 year old
like there was nothing cool there's no
skateboard you know you couldn't really
you couldn't really look at things and
that's why i keep pushing people like
the thing that you are great at right
now
that you like maybe somebody watching
this right now
is
incredibly gravitated towards floral
arrangements
like they just can't help it they just
like go to the nursery and
like they're obsessed
if you're 17 right now
and you're like i like the thing that is
the most important to me comes the most
natural to me the thing i want to do all
the time is be crazy with doing floral
arrangements it's going to be hard for
you to see the rock star
of floral arrangements they exist
there's people that do weddings and
stuff but it's not like we like none of
us can name the [ __ ] lebron of floral
arrangements
my argument is
but you couldn't do that with tony hawk
you couldn't say tony hawk or you or
others in 1982 if skateboarding was your
most important thing it hadn't happened
yet
with video games booga for fortnite that
guy didn't exist
my son knows who booga is for fortnite
but in 1987 when we all [ __ ] with
video games there wasn't a single famous
video game player
so like for everybody at home right now
that has something that doesn't
seemingly look like it's the thing
it might become the thing and why
compromise and become a lawyer or a
skateboarder or an entrepreneur when
you're the [ __ ] greatest floral
arrangement person of all time and just
keep going with it
because it because the world might come
to you i think i think it will i think i
believe in like the law of attraction
and i do if
if you're that obsessed with something
you're that great of something the world
will
re-organize itself i agree
you become you become the [ __ ]
torchbearer of the thing and if nothing
else life is the world is big and the
world is small if nothing else you'll
just enjoy what the [ __ ] you do for the
rest of your life and your little world
will [ __ ] with you you'll be the best
floral ranger of the thousand people
that you know that do floral arrangement
that's why i feel really good about like
i was a single child growing up
and i was you know super shy as i said
but that's why i feel
like that helped me in the sense because
like
whatever i fell into whatever i
was drawn to and i became obsessed with
i had nobody else around me to tell me
yo that's whack is stupid stop thinking
about that oh yeah that's [ __ ] dumb
why are you doing that like i had nobody
to tell me this is cool or not cool it
was just like i was just drawn to what i
was drawn to and i would go into it
full-heartedly and i would run its
course and i'd go on to the next thing
or whatever and then i found
skateboarding but i never had an older
brother or cousin everybody all around
to tell me like you're an idiot stupid
you can't do that or whatever it was
just like open road it's funny you say
that i i'm the oldest
and i i think a lot about had i been the
youngest
would things have been
framed up for me differently
and especially being an 80s child it
wasn't even your parents you just went
outside and [ __ ] discovered yeah yeah
yeah and i think a lot of my friends
who have siblings the youngest one is
the toughest one of course because they
got everybody beating them down this one
is
the sissiest one well not me i'm much
tougher
i'm kidding
thank you bro thank you i'm so excited
about this you can't even imagine
[Music]